a few years ago if a picture were made
in New York Chicago Pomona anywhere but
Hollywood nobody would look at it Europe
of course didn't even exist I think it
was world war two that brought it to our
attention but today even though we like
to think of Hollywood as the film
capital of the world we know that motion
pictures is an international art and we
respect the merits of any picture no
matter where it was made or in what
language to introduce the award for the
best foreign language film of the year
we go to Paris for the international
star and two-time Academy Award winner
for Gaslight and Anastasia miss Ingrid
Bergman
in recognition of the fine film work
done throughout the world the Academy
presents its foreign language film award
in countries all over the world
organizations similar to the Academy are
charged with the task of selecting their
outstanding pictures and then these are
sent to Hollywood and viewed by all the
members of the Academy and five pictures
are nominated for the Foreign Language
Film Award the president through the
Academy mr. Wendell curry will announce
these five pictures so honored and
present the Oscar to the winner ladies
and gentlemen mr. Wender Gauri may I say
first this was most proud and happy to
be able to preserve nominated as the
best foreign language film of 1962
Electra Michael Cote honors production
from Greece the four days of Naples
botanas Metro from Italy keeper of
promises given word to the distri Brazil
Sun decency bell Roman Pines production
from France try Yukon dr. Lawrence motto
from Mexico to win a police bill
the winner is France for Sunday's
well I must say I'm very proud
especially on behalf of my crew my
actress particular Nicole Cassell little
patty shivaji and my producers mr.
roland vines and his partners and well
what else could I say thank you very
very much and I said Mexico whoo oh yes
one more thing maybe the next title of
my film will be Monday and Oscar
you